the u.s. is changing the way it deals
with American hostages held by what it
calls terrorist organizations it will
now be legal for families of those who
have been kidnapped to pay a ransom if
they feel they need to the White House
launched a review of their hostage
policy last fall after several
high-profile executions including that
of journalist James Foley President
Nixon started a policy of refusing to
pay ransoms for the return of American
hostages and it has continued ever since
anti-terrorism laws were made stricter
after 911 and spelt out the penalties
for providing material support to what
they call foreign terrorist
organizations because of this American
families feared prosecution if they paid
up other countries however have been
willing to pay kidnapping is big
business and citizens from France and
Spain for example have been released
after payment some like James Foley's
mother argue that the u.s. could have
saved lives if it had done the same I
pray that our government would be
willing to learn from the mistakes that
were made and to acknowledge that there
are better ways for American citizens to
be treated but others worry that making
ransoms an option will only encourage
kidnapping for profit by groups like
Isis so would you pay to free a loved
one or where the old rules right